it is the second official day of e3
today and the news is still rolling in
heart so let's get you covered off on
everything that mattered in today's
episode brought to you by Qualcomm
Snapdragon LT modems for epically fast
LTE speeds Phil Spencer has told us a
little more about the upcoming Xbox one
Scorpio the Xbox boss dress that you
will need a 4k TV to get the most out of
the device and if you don't have one
you're probably better off picking up
the xbox one s should you want a new
console Spencer did say it would be a
premium price above that of the xbox one
s which will start at three hundred
bucks projects copio has a release
window in the holiday season of next
year Sony may not have been ready to
discuss the more powerful ps4 near
during their conference but they did
express surprise over Microsoft
revealing a console which won't be out
for over a year as for the games today
we found out that the new god of war
game does not feature the original voice
actor for kratos crate haces original
voice actor TC carson wrote on twitter
that sony decided to go in a new
direction for the voice actor this time
and encouraged his followers to let the
publisher know what they thought this
seems like a good spot for a segue so be
sure to let me know what you thought
about today's news and everything that's
been happening at e3 and stay tuned to
GameSpot's before all the latest